bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre cet après-midi
sur notre antenne à l'examen en seconde
lecture du projet de loi pour la
refondation de l'école la semaine
dernière en commission les sénateurs ont
adopté conforme le texte voté par les
députés à l'assemblée nationale ce qui
signifie que cet après midi il ne
devrait y avoir aucune modification en
séance publique pour une adoption
définitive de ce texte d'ici la fin de
la journée je vous rappelle l'objectif
de ce projet loi défendu par le ministre
vincent peillon la création de 60000
postes dans l'éducation nationale dans
les cinq années à venir mais aussi la
remise en place de la formation des
enseignants elle avait été supprimée par
le gouvernement fillon
et enfin un renforcement de la
scolarisation pour les enfants de moins
de 3 ans alors sans plus tarder
direction l'hémicycle pour suivre les
débats bon après midi à tous l'ordre du
jour appelle la discussion en deuxième
lecture du projet de loi adopté avec
modifications par l'assemblée nationale
d'orientation et de programmation pour
la refondation de l'école de la
république
dans la discussion générale la parole
est à monsieur vincent peillon ministre
de l'éducation nationale vous avez la
parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs nous commencions
cet après midi l'examen en deuxième
lecture au sénat de la loi sur la
refondation de l'école de la république
ce sera peut-être d'ailleurs le dernier
examen de cette loi qui marquent eux la
priorité telle qu'elle avait été définie
par le président de la république
je voudrais donc brièvement pour nous
permettre de travailler vous remercier
et remercier les assemblées de leurs
travaux et particulièrement la vôtre
vous rappeler qu'en première lecture
l'assemblée nationale avait déposé 6 161
amendements deux sens ont été adoptés
que à la première lecture au sénat 425
amendements avaient été déposés 118 part
du travail
la commission avait été adoptée à
nouveau à l'assemblée nationale des
amendements ont été déposés en seconde
lecture mais et je veux y ait insisté le
travail important qui avait été accompli
au sénat a été respectée c'était par
rapport aux enrichissement du texte non
seulement une parole engagée mais
l'intérêt même de la loi de refondation
est donc l'intérêt des élèves
la rédaction telle qu'elle avait été
remaniée en première lecture au sénat
avait permis des avancées notables sur
des éléments essentiels l'éducation
artistique et culturelle
le socle commun de compétences de
connaissances et de culture
la carte des formations et sa définition
la comptabilisation
ce matin encore en répondant à des
questions à l'assemblée nationale
je pouvais répondre à un parlementaire
de l'opposition la comptabilisation des
enfants de moins de 3 ans pour ce qui
concerne l'ouverture des classes les
secteurs de recrutement commun à
plusieurs collèges publics
l'espace à usage des parents
donc un certain nombre de mesures
importantes avaient été introduites
l'éducation à l'environnement et au
développement durable
aussi elles ont été conservés tels quels
par l'assemblée nationale en commission
vous avez pu le 18 juin
adopté à nouveau le texte sans qu'il y
ait d'amendements et je m'en réjouis
j'ai entendu tout au long de l'année ce
qui pouvait se dire sur cette loi de
refondation de l'école de la république
cela a peu d'importance ce qui est
important c'est ce que nous avons engagé
ce que nous avons engagé personne sauf
pour des raisons qui ne concerne pas le
fond du sujet que nous traitons ne peut
être contre nous avons engagé la
priorité aux primaires les uns et les
autres qu'on vienne et depuis combien de
temps que dans notre pays le point
faible de notre système éducatif c'était
l'absence de moyens accordés aux
primaires les plus faibles je vous
rappelle taux d'encadrement des pays de
l'osce et ce matin encore l'oci lieu qui
rendait public ses études à 11 heures
marquées à quel point dans notre pays il
y à un écart entre le primaire et le
secondaire dans ce que nous demandons
aux enseignants ça vient de très loin et
le président de la république avait pris
cet engagement dans la campagne
nous l'avons marquer deuxièmement la
mise en place plutôt que la remise en
place d'une formation des enseignants
c'est le facteur essentiel de la
réussite éducative
j'entends sur les écoles supérieures du
professorat et d'éducation et julie un
certain nombre d'inexactitudes parce que
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire au sénat
la semaine dernière oui c'est une
rupture
en réponse à une question de madame la
présidente blandin c'est une rupture par
rapport à ce que nous avons fait jusque
là
et cette rupture il fallait la faire car
nous avons besoin d'une entrée
professionnalisantes dans le métier
elle aura lieu
dès la licence elle s'accentuera au même
elle continuera en m2 parce que nous
avons besoin c'est l'entrée
professionnalisantes d'une alternance
elle aura lieu avec des stages qui
seront proposées avant même le m1 et
dans le m
et le concours ne sera pas une voix de
césure je vois la préoccupation sur les
reçus collés
parce que contrairement aux dernières
années où l'esprit de compétition entre
les universités s'est substituée à
l'esprit de coopération nous avons donné
un cadre national et nous avons la
procédure d'accréditation qui nous
permet d'exiger qu'il est
cette entrée professionnalisante et
cette entrée progressive dans le métier
est bien entendu la prise en charge de
ce que doit savoir faire l'enseignant du
21e siècle sa discipline certes les
didactiques évidemment mais aussi tout
le reste les usages du numérique
l'égalité filles-garçons l'appréhension
pour les enfants en situation de
handicap la laïcité et les réponses
qu'il faut apporter un certain nombre de
situations le travail en équipe
la capacité à construire le rapport
entre l'école et ce qui est extérieur à
l'école et nous avons souhaité vous le
savez c'est fondamental que dans ces
écoles il y est la présence des
praticiens aux côtés des universitaires
à la fois ce qui est enseigne encore que
ce soit dans le primaire notre réseau
des maîtres formateurs mais aussi dans
le secondaire et bien entendu aussi les
partenaires de l'école c'est une tâche
colossale mais je dois dire que le
travail qui a été accompli depuis un an
permettra qu'à la rentrée les nouveaux
stagiaires et ils ont retrouvé l'année
de stage puissent bénéficier de cet
enseignement qui là encore j'ai vu les
incompréhensions on a du mal à avoir
percé le neuf dans ce pays assura
formation initiale et formation continue
professorat et métiers de l'éducation
priorité aux primaires remise en place
ou invention d'une nouvelle formation
des enseignants services publics du
numérique éducatif réforme de nos
procédures d'orientation remise en place
des instruments qui seront là dès le
mois d'octobre conseil supérieur des
programmes conseil national de
l'évaluation et qui permettront à
l'éducation nationale de reprendre le
mouvement qui doit être le sien
sur tous ces sujets vous avez
considérablement enrichi notre texte les
moyens sont présents au rendez-vous 6700
emplois seront créés en dehors de la
remise en place de l'année de stage à la
rentrée sur le terrain j'ai eu
l'occasion d'en vous de vous en préciser
les chiffres moitié pour le primaire
moitié pour le secondaire qui n'est pas
abandonné nous avons une poussée
démographique
nous arrivons à y répondre et nous
orientons tous les moyens
supplémentaires vers les zones en
difficulté car là encore les études sont
implacables non seulement nous avons une
difficulté sur les apprentissages
fondamentaux mais nous avons une
difficulté particulière qui
l'aggravation des inégalités et donc de
la cohésion nationale et la solidarité à
l'égard des zones urbaines sensibles de
certains territoires de ruraux et de nos
départements et territoires d'outre-mer
c'est pour cela que conformément aux
engagements du président de la
république tous les moyens
supplémentaires dès cette année seront
affectés dans ces endroits
particulièrement sensible c'est vrai
pour l'accueil des moins de 3 ans c'est
vrai pour le principe plus de maîtres
queux de classe ce sera vrai aussi pour
notre action en faveur des collèges
je ne veux pas être plus long il s'agit
bien des fondements
nous les avons ensemble reposez vous
avez permis déjà de les étayer mieux et
nous avons devant nous un calendrier de
travail chargé calendrier sur le collège
j'entends il faudrait parler du collège
bien sûr mais ça fait plusieurs mois que
autour de la direction générale les
enseignements scolaires nous réunissons
tous les partenaires pour bien entendu
proposer cette réforme du collège qui
doit suivre dans l'ordre la réforme du
primaire
bien entendu les préoccupations
fondamentales qui sont les nôtres
concernant directement l'éducation
prioritaire
elle concerne près de 20% de nos
écoliers et de nos collégiens
elles ne donnent pas les résultats
nécessaires malgré l'engagement des
personnels
nous avons à traiter cette question pour
mettre fin à ces injustices et
permettent la réussite éducative de tous
ce chantier va être engagé celui des
missions des professeurs nous l'avons
fait déjà et nous avons commencé de le
faire pour les professeurs des écoles
nous continuerons et cette discussion
s'ouvrira à la rentrée il y a ceux qui
ne veulent rien changer
il ya ceux qui s'avancent vers l'avenir
en regardant dans le rétroviseur il ya
ceux qui pensent qu'il faudrait aussi
citer éternellement les débats d'antan
entre l'instruction et l'éducation entre
les républicains et les pédagogues entre
les moyens et les fins entre la quantité
et la qualité
et puis il ya ceux qui ont le sens de
l'intérêt général
la connaissance de notre histoire qui
ont fait l'analyse de la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui avec un
système éducatif en peine et qui veulent
alors surmonter ces obstacles
ça ne se fera pas en un jour il faut de
la méthode et la méthode ce chemin nous
nous sommes mis en chemin il faut de la
détermination
elle est présente au rendez vous elle
bénéficie de l'appui des plus hautes
autorités de l'état le premier ministre
et le président de la république nous
avons les moyens de mener une grande
réforme
je suis heureux qu à ce stade cette
réforme était enrichi dans ce dialogue
avec les assemblées et je crois que je
vous l'avais dit la dernière fois nous
sommes là conforme à beaucoup plus une
attitude politique à ce qui doit être en
permanence le soutien d'une attitude
politique un engagement d'esprit public
et un engagement de valeur nous avons
besoin pour réussir cette réforme de
l'engagement de tous
nous sommes plus intelligents a
plusieurs que tout seul nous voulons
l'enseigné aux élèves nous avons à mai
le mettre en pratique nous mêmes je
remercie les groupes parlementaires qui
ont enrichi le texte et j'appelle les
autres car je sais que pour beaucoup
d'entre eux ils partagent je le vois
d'ailleurs parfois on est aux confins de
l'absurde
lorsque des sénateurs ou députés de
l'opposition ne disent mais alors pour
les moins de 3 ans comment on peut
contrôler que ça arrive bien et pour le
plus de maîtres queux de place et pour
le nombre d'enseignants dans ma
situation et pour les écoles supérieures
ces avancées appartiennent à toute la
nation
elles sont dans l'intérêt des élèves je
remercie les groupes qui ont permis
d'enrichir ce texte lui donnait sa
cohérence son ancrage républicain et je
souhaite que les autres puissent
utiliser cette dernière discussion
parlementaire pour montrer que leur seul
souci c'est l'intérêt des élèves et
l'intérêt de la france
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à madame françoise cartron rapporteur de
la commission de la culture de
l'éducation et de la communication
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale madame
la présidente de la commission de la
culture de l'éducation de la
communication mesdames et messieurs mes
chers collègues le jour de son
investiture le président de la
république avait adressé ses premiers
mots à toutes celles et ceux qui font le
choix au quotidien de servir la
connaissance est d'éveiller les
consciences au moment de prendre ses
fonctions par son hommage rendu à
jules-ferry bâtisseurs de notre école
publique laïque gratuite et obligatoire
le président de la république avait
souhaité rappeler dès les premières
heures du quinquennat la première des
priorités celle accordée à la jeunesse
celle accordée à la refondation de cette
grande maison commune qu'est l'école de
la république la refondation de l'école
s'incarnera d'ici peu dans une loi
d'orientation et de programmation
issue d'un travail de concertation dont
nous avons reconnu ici l'ampleur et la
qualité fruits également d'un débat
parlementaire riche rigoureux elle
constituera sans contexte cette feuille
de route indispensable que nous aurons à
suivre dans les années à venir
avec toujours cet objectif que l'école
retrouve avec les moyens budgétaires et
pédagogiques nécessaires
son ambition de réussite pour tous
qu'elle demeure ce lieu privilégié de la
connaissance de l'intégration de la
véritable égalité que vivent à travers
elle l'esprit de notre république
monsieur le ministre vous avez su être à
l'écouté des parlementaires de leurs
arguments et de leurs propositions
cette approche constructive aura permis
des avancées importantes
des améliorations ont été apportées à
chacune des étapes du processus
législatif diverses sensibilités ont pu
s'exprimer au service d'une ambition
commune permettre à notre école d'être
plus juste pour tous et exigeantes pour
chacun il ya tout juste un mois le
projet de loi était adopté au sénat en
première lecture
quatre jours et quatre nuits des
échanges approfondis on perd on permis
de consolider les fondations et les
fondamentaux que nous assignons à notre
école
là même qui croient au progrès à la
justice sociale qui ne se résignent pas
face aux inégalités sociales et
culturelles
suite au vote intervenu dans cet
hémicycle mon homologue rapporteur à
l'assemblée nationale et les députés
membres de la commission des affaires
culturelles et de l'éducation ont estimé
comme point d équilibre avait été
atteint je partage entièrement ce
constat les 138 amendement adopté par
notre commission
les 99 autres voté en séance publique
ont permis aux sénatrice et aux
sénateurs d'apporter comme je l'avais
dit en conclusion des débats le 25 mai
leur pierre ou plutôt leurs multiples
petites pierres à cette entreprise de
redressement sur les 60 articles
modifiés par notre assemblée 26
reviennent aujourd'hui 32 avait été
adopté conforme à l'issue de la première
navette trente quatre l'ont été lors du
second passage devant les députés
la majeure partie des modifications
nouvellement intégrés par nos collègues
parlementaires sont d'ordre
rédactionnelles ces apports nous les
jugerons opportun sans bouleverser aucun
des grands équilibres
ils ont eu comme visée principal de
parfaire certaines formulations voilà
donc je le crois un travail législatif
réussi et c'est bien cette démarche de
co construction que nous défendons pour
notre école un travail collaboratif en
lieu et place d'un système parfois trop
hiérarchiser concurrentiel devenu pour
nombre de nos élèves anxiogène et
inefficace c'est cette idée d'une
réussite collective par le collectif que
nous avons défendues constamment cette
idée irrigue le texte que nous apprêtons
à voter dans ces dispositions et dans sa
conception
l'article 3 à que nous avons inséré en
première lecture dans le projet de loi
l'incarnent en tous points celui ci qui
redéfinit les missions et rappelle les
valeurs fondamentales du service public
de l'éducation n'a été que retouché à la
marge par les députés
il nous convient ainsi la reconnaissance
du principe selon lequel tout enfant est
capable d'apprendre de progresser la
coopération comme valeurs cardinales de
l'action de la communauté éducative la
lutte contre les inégalités sociales
territoriales de réussite
la prise en compte par les
établissements de la mixité sociale
tous ces éléments essentiels je crois
que nous pouvons éprouver de la fierté à
les voir gravé dans le premier article
du code de l'éducation afin de
réaffirmer la démocratisation du système
scolaire
c'est collectivement par un série
d'amendements que nous avons posé les
bases symbolique et fixer le cap de la
refondation c'est de cette manière aussi
que l'école de la république pourra
durablement renouer avec sa vocation
émancipatrice universel jean zay
illustre parmi vos prédécesseurs
monsieur le ministre avait sous le front
populaire
par sa détermination construit le
système d'une école unique sans
distinction de classe sociale dans
l'enseignement primaire
c'est cette oeuvre que nous devons
poursuivre cité jean zay c'est aussi
réaffirmé la nécessaire vigilance qu'il
nous faut avoir républicains pour
défendre les valeurs universelles de
l'humaniste c'est pourquoi nous avons
également fait figurer trois valeurs
fondamentales que sont les gars dignité
des êtres humains la liberté de
conscience et la laïcité
trois valeurs que le service public
d'éducation a vocation à faire acquérir
à tous les élèves en même temps que les
connaissances les compétences et la
culture
ce sera également le sens de
l'enseignement civique et morale sur
cela il doit y avoir nécessairement
consensus de même que sur la garantie de
l'universalité du droit à l'éducation
par un renfoncement de l'obligation
d'inclusion scolaire de tous les enfants
marie lise campion rapporteur pour avis
au nom de la commission des affaires
sociales a été à l'origine de plusieurs
amendements qui ont donné corps au
principe avec le développement de la
coopération entre l'éducation nationale
et le secteur médico social avec l'objet
yves de continuité du parcours
déscolarisation des enfants en situation
de handicap ou encore avec l'adaptation
des épreuves d'examen pour les élèves
présentant un trouble de santé
invalidant plus généralement les
dispositions du projet de loi en matière
de santé scolaire élément essentiel pour
améliorer le bien-être des enfants et
ainsi accroître leurs chances de
réussite ont été considérablement
enrichie au sénat l'assemblée nationale
a validé la plupart de nos avancées sur
ce terrain de première importance
sans revenir dans le détail sur toutes
les mesures je me réjouis que la
rédaction remanié en première lecture
par le sénat et ai été conservé en ce
qui concerne l'éducation artistique et
culturelle
le nouvel enseignement d'éducation à
l'environnement et développement durable
le socle commun et l'élaboration de la
carte régionale des formations
professionnelles de même ce que nous
avons apportées sur l'école maternelle a
été adopté conforme notamment la
comptabilisation des moins de 3 ans dans
les effectifs et les éléments de
formation spécifiques à destination des
enseignants
cela participera de la nécessaire
sécurisation des parcours scolaires par
un accompagnement renforcé de qualité
dès le plus jeune âge en particulier
pour les enfants de milieux sociaux
défavorisés
nous le savons les moyens
supplémentaires octroyées considérable
en cette période de grandes difficultés
ne produiront leur effet que s'il
coïncide avec une évolution en
profondeur des pratiques
professionnelles et pédagogique de plus
en s'adressant en premier lieu aux
écoles des quartiers populaires et à
certaines zones rurales isolées
ils permettent de donner plus à ceux qui
ont moins
les députés ont ainsi conservé intact
l'ensemble des avancées très importantes
que nous avions collectivement fait pour
soutenir l'enseignement des langues et
cultures régionales
ils se sont prononcés favorablement à
l'initiation à la diversité linguistique
en plus des enseignements formelle de
langue celle parlée
les familles pour être utilisés à cette
fin
l'intégration de la continuité
d'apprentissage des langues étrangères
entre le primaire et le secondaire voté
en seconde lecture à l'assemblée
nationale est particulièrement bienvenue
cela renforce en plus la liaison cm2 6e
en outre ont été également approuvé les
apports du sénat pour ce qui concerne
l'encadrement de la mise à disposition
des locaux scolaires dont nous avions
souhaité qu'elles respectent les
principes de neutralité politique
commerciale et de laïcité la possibilité
de créer des secteurs de recrutement
commun à plusieurs collèges publics afin
de favoriser la mixité sociale c'est
bien en soutenant la cohérence et la
synergie entre tous les partenaires de
l'école que nous feront naître des
approches nouvelles
cette démarche partenariale que nous
encourageant a pris corps plus
globalement dans les amendements que
nous avions adoptée concernant
l'ensemble des acteurs de la communauté
éducative l'essentiel de nos apports
permettant de renforcer la place des
parents dans l'école ont été approuvés
par nos collègues députés
c'est le cas de la suppression de
l'article 4 ter qui remettait en cause
l'accord des parents pour l'orientation
et l'accompagnement des enfants
handicapés
c'est aussi valable pour l'obligation
nouvelle que nous avions faite au
conseil d'administration des
établissements de dresser annuellement
le bilan des actions menées à
destination des parents est également
conservé la redéfinition des missions
des personnels enseignants pour prévoir
qu'ils tiennent informé les parents et
les aident à suivre leur scolarité
la scolarité de leurs enfants enfin
comme nous en avions convenu dans tous
les établissements sera désormais prévu
un espace à l'usagé des parents d'élèves
et de leurs délégués concernant la mise
en oeuvre des dispositifs dead le sénat
et l'assemblée nationale sont arrivés je
le crois un compromis si l'école prend
l'initiative de mettre en oeuvre une
aide appropriée aux enfants en
difficulté celle ci ne sera pas limitée
aux ppr eux et les parents resteront
impliquer l'ensemble des mesures que
nous avions prises en faveur de
l'enseignement agricole ont été
également préservées notamment
la reconnaissance du ministre de
l'agriculture comme un interlocuteur à
part entière du conseil national de
l'évaluation du système scolaire la
fourniture par l'état des manuels
scolaires dans les établissements
agricoles la préservation des classes de
4e de l'enseignement agricole dont la
pédagogie propre comprend des stages la
prise en charge par les régions du
transport pédagogique le 16 mai stéphane
le foll conclut et la vaste concertation
sur l'avenir de l'enseignement agricole
en rappelant ses spécificités et son
rôle de premier plan dans la promotion
sociale et la réussite scolaire nous
devons tirer profit en terme de
pédagogie des en terme de pédagogie
l'organisation des expérimentations
menées au sein des foyers d'innovation
est essentielle
oui une profonde transformation de notre
système éducatif ne peut se faire que
par la participation de tous elle se
fera demain avait des maîtres bien
formés au sein des sp créé dès la
rentrée 2013
école de formation repenser ou comme
vous l'avez dit formation théorique et
professionnels en constitueront les deux
piliers comme vous pouvez le constater
l'immense majorité nos amendements ont
été confirmés par l'assemblée nationale
les modifications qu'elle a portée en
deuxième lecture aux articles restent en
discussion relève the lady
essentiellement de rectification
rédactionnelles
je me félicite dans de l' équilibre
stable ainsi atteint entre les deux
chambres
aussi si j'ai bien pris en considération
les quarante six amendements déposés sur
le texte et dont nous allons débattre
cet après midi je me prononce au nom de
la commission pour une adoption conforme
des articles restent en discussion avant
que la discussion générale ne débute
je voudrais remercier une nouvelle fois
tous mes collègues de la commission qui
ont participé aux longues séances de ces
dernières semaines madame la présidente
marie christine blandin ainsi que les
administrateurs les fonctionnaires de
cette commission qui nous ont assisté et
effectuer un immense travail
cette loi de refondation porte votre
volonté monsieur le ministre de
permettre à tous les enfants de france
de trouver le chemin de la réussite
de l'épanouissement grâce à la maîtrise
du savoir et de la connaissance
cette volonté qui nous permet de croire
à l'avenir qui nous mobilisera toutes et
tous afin de relever le défi qui est
devant nous car comme l'écrivait jean
jacques rousseau
il n'y a pas de véritable action sans
volonté merci madame le rapporteur dans
la suite de la discussion générale la
parole est à monsieur jacques legendre
pour le groupe ump
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
mam le rapporteur la présidente de la
commission mes chers collègues
la commission de la culture et de
l'éducation vient de se prononcer pour
une adoption conforme alors monsieur le
ministre vous pouvez penser que la messe
est dite et que vous avez atteint vos
objectifs
malgré les mises en garde et critique
les remarques nombreuses venant non
seulement des bancs des parlementaires
de l'opposition mais aussi de nombreux
responsables du monde enseignant et les
organisations syndicales enseignantes et
oui pour vous monsieur le ministre
améliorer notre système éducatif passe
des nécessairement par une augmentation
du nombre de postes encadrant les élèves
la principale mesure de votre projet de
loi c'est la création de 60000 postes ce
qui en est fait n'est pas rien dans le
contexte budgétaire que nous connaissons
at on réellement étudié l'opportunité
les risques d'une telle mesure
je m'étais déjà interrogé lors de la
première lecture du texte alors je
souhaite revenir sur ce sujet primordial
tout d'abord monsieur le ministre si
vous consacrez une telle part du budget
éducation renouvellement ou à la
création de poste vous ne pourrez régler
en même temps la question de la révision
de la rémunération des enseignants
or les enseignants français gagnent
entre 15 et 20% de moins que leurs
homologues des pays membres de l'union
européenne et de l' ocde à leur début de
carrière comme après 15 ans d'ancienneté
et seuls 6 malgré des efforts trop
récents sans doute de l'ancienne
majorité
cette révision de la rémunération serait
bien plus qu'un simple ajustement
il s'agit pour les enseignants d'une
reconnaissance de la valeur et de la
difficulté de leur métier il faut
améliorer l'attractivité de cette
profession car la réussite des élèves
dépend avant tout de la qualité des eaux
saignant ensuite vous ne dites pas vous
trouverez le financement de ces postes
deux solutions se présentent à vous vous
augmenter les charges de l'état ce qui
paraît difficilement tenable en cette
période vous prenez le risque de
déséquilibrer les effectifs de la
fonction publique
il faudra bien supprimer des postes
ailleurs puisque le nombre de
fonctionnaires est censé dans le même
temps ne pas augmenter
n'est ce pas monsieur le président de la
commission de la défense
enfin et surtout le postulat que vous
énoncez la réussite des élèves seraient
liées au nombre d'enseignants ne répond
à aucune donnée reconnu les études
internationales
mesurons les écarts existent entre pays
montrait déjà que ceux ayant les
meilleurs résultats ne consacrer pas
pour autant des moyens que autant de
moyens que la france à l'encadrement des
élèves
nous disposons maintenant d'un avis très
récent lors de l'examen du texte en
première lecture la cour des comptes a
publié un rapport édifiant sur la
gestion des enseignants venant
totalement contredire vos choix ceux du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
selon la cour des comptes le résultat
les résultats insatisfaisants que nous
connaissons ne proviennent pas d'un
manque de moyens budgétaires ou
d'enseignants mais d'une utilisation
défaillante des moyens existants et la
cour des comptes recommande précisément
ce dont je viens de parler une réforme
d'ensemble des modalités de gestion des
personnels enseignants revoyant leurs
obligations réglementaires de service la
valorisation des ressources humaines et
leur condition d'affectation
on aurait pu croire que la publication
du rapport amènerait le gouvernement à
revoir sa copie vous maintenez le cap
que vous avez fixé
sourd aux avertissements quand bien même
ils proviennent d'une institution
reconnue pour la qualité de ses travaux
et son impartialité
certes l'exercice de remise en question
est difficile surtout lorsqu'il s'agit
d'une promesse électorale les en
refusant de prendre en compte les avis
des spécialistes vous montrer à quel
point la politique du gouvernement est
en décalage par rapport aux réalités du
terrain quant aux autres dispositions du
projet de loi
elle vise surtout à remettre en cause
les choix de la majorité précédente
je relève l'affirmation du collège
unique alors que le maintien d'élèves en
difficulté dans une voie généraliste est
un véritable gâchis
l'enjeu aujourd'hui n'est plus la
massification de l'enseignement mais
bien la personnalisation de celui ci
voyez aussi combien un choix que vous
avez fait semble-t-il me désole la
suppression des internats d'excellence
jetait sur le ministre samedi encore
dans une ville qui a un internat
d'excellence dans la région du nord à
douai et j'ai vu des enseignants et
toute une équipe mobilisée autour de cet
internat d'excellence et désespéré à
l'idée que cette expérience de
maintenant trois années ne puisse pas
être poursuivi et il s'agit bien là
d'une action certes coûteuse mais au
bénéfice dans de jeunes particulièrement
défavorisées et en particulière
difficulté doit aussi évidemment
reparler de votre affirmation du collège
unique alors que le maintien d'élèves en
difficulté dans une voie généraliste est
un véritable gâchis
l'enjeu aujourd'hui n'est plus la
massification je le disais mais la
personnification je m'inquiète aussi de
la dilution des matières plutôt que du
renforcement du socle des connaissances
et des compétences et en plus un socle
définies par décret et non par la loi le
socle c'est un élément essentiel c'est
la colonne vertébrale de notre système
éducatif
il est légitime il est normal qu'elle sa
définition soit établie ici au parlement
ou non sont aussi l isolement de la
maternelle au sein d'un site unique
alors qu'il faudrait ouvrir davantage la
dernière année de grande section à
l'apprentissage de la lecture en la
rapprochant du clu de la classe primaire
du cp de l'école primaire une formation
des enseignants sur laquelle nous devons
nous prononcer
nous ne connaissons pas le réel contenu
ce qui fait craindre la réapparition des
défauts des anciens du fn la remise en
cause du système de notation et des
devoirs à la maison
dans un souci d'égalité risme
systématique
les mesures dont je viens de parler ne
sont pas des mesures de refondation de
l'école pourquoi votre texte soit un
texte d'ampleur il aurait fallu moins
d'idéologie monsieur le ministre est
moins de rigidité
le projet de loi ne prévoit rien pour
accroître l'autonomie des établissements
qui est pourtant un sujet essentiel
rien n'est dit sur la création du statut
des directeurs d'école par exemple ce
n'est qu'en introduisant davantage de
souplesse en permettant des
expérimentations évalué de notre système
éducatif pourra progresser bien d'autres
sujets n'ont pas été traités lorsqu'ils
ont été évoqués dans la longue liste du
rapport annexé aucun contenu n'est venu
leur donner une direction concrètes
votre projet de loi est insuffisant
concernant la réforme de l'orientation
de l'apprentissage des liens entre
écoles l'entreprise où l'équilibré des
filières du baccalauréat ce texte défi
décidément sera à revoir ou à compléter
le budget de l'éducation est plus
important de l'état lui donne une
mauvaise orientation serait extrêmement
dommageable pour la réussite de nos
élèves et la progression notre système
éducatif ans on sait qu'en ce monsieur
le ministre ne serais pas étonné si je
vous dis que le groupe ump votera contre
ce projet de loi
je vous remercie merci mon cher collègue
la parole est à madame brigitte gonthier
maurin pour le groupe crc
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
madame la rapporteure chers collègues le
texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui en
deuxième lecture a connu cela a été dit
peu de modifications par rapport au
texte issu de nos travaux en première
lecture au sénat
cela doit être saluée même si je
regrette que la priorité à l'utilisation
de logiciels libres voté à l'article 10
à notre initiative et été amoindri par
un amendement du gouvernement
pour le reste les modifications que nous
avions obtenus ont été maintenus ainsi
notre combat pour privilégier une
coopération état région plutôt qu'une
m'a mise de la région sur la carte des
formations professionnelles initiales
prévue dans le projet de loi a trouvé un
début de réponse puisque cette carte ne
sera pas déterminée par la seule région
mais après accord du recteur vous devez
donc être monsieur le ministre via les
recteurs le garant de l'égalité de
traitement sur le territoire le garant
que l'enseignement professionnel ne sera
pas instrumentalisé à des fins de seul
employabilité ni concurrencé par
l'apprentissage que votre gouvernement
entend par ailleurs promouvoir davantage
nous avons aussi obtenu le retrait par
le gouvernement de deux mesures issues
du projet de loi de décentralisation
confiant à la région la définition et la
mise en oeuvre du service public
d'orientation tout au long de la vie
ce débat nous le savons reviendra au
moment de l'examen du projet de loi de
décentralisation consacrés aux régions
et nous mènerons pour notre part à
nouveau bataille sur le socle commun il
est désormais précisé que je cite le
socle doit permettre la poursuite
d'études
la construction d'un avenir personnel et
professionnel
la suppression de la référence aux
compétences clés européenne n'a pas été
réintroduite cette disposition crée une
première brèche dans la conception
utilitariste et minimaliste du soap une
brèche modeste
mais sur laquelle nous pourrons nous
appuyer pour exiger que le socle qui va
être redéfini ne soit par romain ramené
à une version minimes minimaliste et
utilitariste nos propositions sur les
écoles supérieures du professorat et de
l'éducation ont été maintenus dont celle
qui ajoute aux missions des sp c'est
l'jeu site de préparer les enseignants
métier de lance de l'entrée dans les
apprentissages et à la prise en compte
de la difficulté scolaire dont le
contenu des enseignements et la démarche
d'apprentissage comme je lai indiqué la
semaine dernière lors du débat sur le
projet de loi sur l'enseignement
supérieur et la recherche la mise en
place des sp nous inquiètent les
craintes que suscite la nouvelle
procédure d'accréditation la réalité des
moyens en personnel de formation qui
leur seront réellement accordés pour
fonctionner n'ont pas été levés
nous serons vigilants aussi quant à
l'effectivité de cette mission de
formation initiale et continue pour
d'échouer l'échec scolaire que nous
avons fait introduire mission qui est
pour nous tout à fait essentiel dans la
réalisation du tous capables
cette inscription du tous capables dans
la loi et dans le code de l'éducation a
été possible grâce au travail de
conviction et à la bataille qui n'était
pas gagné d'avancé que nous avons mené
de concert avec notre rapporteur madame
car trop il a donné à voir la
construction positive d'un travail
parlementaire à gauche
chose assez rare pour le souligner ce
débat a permis d'éclairer les postures
des uns des autres
oui l'échec scolaire n'est pas une
fatalité et les différences entre les
élèves ne sont pas naturelles mais bien
socialement construite si ce débat nous
a permis de faire avancer le principe du
tous capables pour trouver sa plénitude
celui ci devrait selon nous
s'accompagner d'une transformation de
l'ensemble du système éducatif car le
défi qui se pose à notre société et donc
à l'école et à un service public
national capable d'y répondre
c'est de celui de la transformation du
rapport aux savoirs pour répondre
à l'exigence d'élévation des
connaissances pour toutes et tous ce fut
notre boussole tout au long du travail
que nous avons mené sur ce projet de loi
or comment y répondre sans une véritable
relance du processus de démocratisation
scolaire
si tous les élèves sont capables
d'apprendre et de réussir
il nous faut alors transformé en
conséquence le service public national
d'éducation seule garantie de l'égalité
territoriale
ce fut le sens des propositions que nous
avons aussi défendu dans ce débat celle
d'un allongement de la scolarité
obligatoire de 3 à 18 ans celle d'une
culture commune ambitieuse pour tous les
élèves
celle d'une orientation moins précoce
enfin déconnecté de l'échec
celle d'une réelle refondations et
revalorisation du métier d'enseignant
qui leur redonne prise sur leur travail
et leur accordent les moyens de faire
évoluer leurs pratiques pour assurer la
réussite de tous les élèves
celle encore d'un service public
national renforcé garant de l'égalité
d'accès aux savoirs sur tous les
territoires face au poids toujours
croissant des inégalités territoriales
qui pèse fortement sur la réussite des
élèves
si nous ne sommes pas hostiles à des
partenariats
ceux ci ne doivent pas en effet servir
de paravent un désengagement de l'état
ou à une avancée du privé ainsi le
rappel à l'ordre du conseil d'état quant
au projet de décret assouplissant les
taux d'encadrement en centre de loisirs
dans le cadre de la réforme des rythmes
scolaires doit être entendu si ses
exigences que nous avons porté n'ont pas
trouvé d'écho favorable
nous les avons mis en débat elle demeure
elle se poseront d'autant avec d'autant
plus d'acuité encore et rapidement
compte tenu du défi incontournable posée
à notre société d'élévation des
connaissances que je rappelais à
l'instant
d'autant que la rentrée s'annonce une
nouvelle fois difficile avec des
effectifs en hausse et des suppressions
de postes qui se font toujours sentir et
qui sont loin d'avoir été résorbé et
vraiment je soutiens ce que disais à
l'instant tiers
président thierry foucaud parce que j'ai
les mêmes remonter dans ma propre
économie l'épreuve de vérité donc
monsieur le ministre se fera au moment
de l'examen du budget le vote que nous
émettrons sur ce texte en deuxième
lecture n'est donc pas un blanc-seing
accordé à la politique éducative du
gouvernement et nous serons à tout
moment vous le rappeler mais je pense
que vous en doutez guerre vous l'aurez
compris ce texte n'est pas celui pour
nous d'une refondation et il nous laisse
encore une impression d'inachevé
c'est pourquoi notre groupe devait
devrait cependant émettre à l'issue de
cette deuxième lecture un vote positif
cependant vous l'aurez également compris
il s'agira d'un vote assorties
d'exigence et donc de grande vigilance
merci ma chère collègue la parole est à
madame françoise férat pour le groupe
u10 uc
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous
abordons cette après midi l'examen en
deuxième lecture du projet de loi
d'orientation et de programmation pour
la refondation de l'école de la
république et je souhaite associer ma
collègue catherine morin desailly à mon
intervention monsieur le ministre
à l'énoncé de cette dénomination nous
pouvions fondé de grands espoirs
les chances de réussite devraient être
les mêmes pour tous et sur tout le
territoire et c'est bien dès la primaire
que tout se joue les écarts sont encore
trop grand aujourd'hui
pire même il s'aggrave en tout premier
lieu
permettez-moi de revenir sur ce que
prévoit l'article 7 concernant le socle
commun des connaissances de compétences
et de culture celui ci est pour nous la
base permettant de progresser de
s'insérer dans la société ainsi que dans
la vie professionnelle
c'est une priorité elle aurait dû être
défini par le législateur à texte
conduit d'une manière réglementaire ne
suffit pas l'acquisition de ces
fondamentaux est la base de toute
réussite et je tiens à rappeler à ce
titre combien je regrette le manque
d'ambition du texte concernant la lutte
contre l'illettrisme pourtant reconnu
grande cause nationale cette année
la première mission de l'école c'est
bien de savoir lire et écrire
dans les faits c'est un nombre croissant
d'élèves qui décrochent qui quittent le
système scolaire sans formation sans
diplôme
et ce sont autant de jeunes qui viennent
augmenter les chiffres du chômage qui ne
cesse de battre de bien tristes records
quelles sont les chances aujourd'hui
d'obtenir un emploi sans qualification
c'est pourquoi face à ces constats
je ne comprends pas le parti pris qui a
été fait notamment quant à
l'apprentissage et la formation
professionnelle l'apprentissage en
france aujourd'hui c'est 420000
apprentis plusieurs centaines de
spécialités de formation donnant accès à
510 activités artisanales 80 % des
apprentis trouvent un emploi dans leur
métier à chefs d'entreprises artisanales
sur deux est issu de l'apprentissage
il s'agit bien là d'une filière
d'excellence
son taux d'insertion professionnelle
après l'obtention d'un diplôme on est la
meilleure preuve et démontre les
qualités et la motivation de tous ces
jeunes je déplore encore une fois que la
place qui peut lui être accordé dans le
système éducatif français souhaite aussi
injuste et peu importante au regard de
ses performances
alors qu'au final les jeunes qui
choisissent cette filière font partie de
ceux qui aujourd'hui tuft à l'emploi
pour rappel la semaine de
l'apprentissage organisé par les
chambres de commerce et d'industrie de
france a eu lieu mi juin
il ya quelques jours seulement et à
cette occasion un sondage ifop cci
france rmc révèle que 55 % des 15 25 ans
sont intéressés par une telle formation
et que globalement l'image de
l'apprentissage est très positive auprès
des jeunes et de leurs parents alors
même monsieur le ministre que se
déroulait ici au sénat les 13e
rencontres de l'apprentissage
vous avez fait voter des dispositions
qui ne leur permettrons plus en 4e
d'avoir des enseignements
complémentaires les préparant à des
formations professionnelles vous êtes
également revenu sur les dispositifs de
la loi cherpion avec la suppression du
préapprentissage et plus précisément du
dima à 14 ans sur ce point d'ailleurs
une zone d'ombré persistent pour ceux
qui ont acquis le socle commun à la fin
de troisième et qui auront quinze ans à
la fin de l'année civile tout comme mon
collègue jean claude merceron sénateur
de vendée
j'ai été interpellé sur cette
problématique il est indispensable de
maintenir au moins la possibilité pour
un jeune qui le souhaite
en sortant de troisième et encore une
fois je répète qui a acquis le socle
commun d'entrée en formation par
apprentissage
aujourd'hui un élève qui aurait 15 ans
dans l'année civile peut perdre un an
cursus et la rédaction actuelle du
projet loi ne permet pas de pallier à
cette difficulté lorsque j'ai évoqué ce
problème lors des débats en première
lecture la ministre george pau-langevin
avait précisé en pratique si un jeune de
14 ans 3/4 acquis le socle commun on
peut envisager des assouplissements
mais en l'état il ne me semble pas utile
de le mentionner dans la loue
nous disait tél pouvez vous me confirmer
aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre que les
jeunes ayant acquis le socle comme à la
sortie de la classe de troisième et qui
auront quinze ans de l'année civile
pourront effectivement entrés en
formation par l'apprentissage et ne
passeront pas ainsi une année précieuse
année pendant laquelle nous pourrions
prendre le risque de les voir décrocher
car empêchés de s'épanouir dans une voie
qu'ils ont choisie car ils l'auront bien
choisi obliger un élève aller en classe
de seconde dans ces conditions serait
contreproductif et nombre de familles
sont de la tante de cette précision
nous nous accordons tous sur la
nécessité que l'orientation sur une
orientation choisie et non subie est
justement une orientation est la grande
absente de ce texte tout comme celui de
l'enseignement supérieur d'ailleurs nous
mesurons le manque à tous niveaux
alors même qu'il en est l'un des piliers
de la réussite et ce texte
hélas pose bien d'autres problèmes il ne
permettra malheureusement pas de
remédier au manque de notre système
scolaire
je ne doute pas que les intentions
étaient bonnes quant à son élaboration
mais pour pouvoir réaliser une réforme
d'envergure
il faut étudier les problématiques dans
leur ensemble et éviter l'écueil de la
précipitation un temps de concertation
aurait permis d'avoir un texte plus
complet et surtout plus efficace je l'
ai déjà dit en première lecture et je le
répète ce projet de loi n'est pas à la
hauteur de ses ambitions
et ce n'est pas le rapport de mai
dernier la cour des comptes qui me
contredira il préconise en effet de
redéfinir le métier d'enseignant de
mieux valoriser les ressources humaines
d'affecter les enseignants en fonction
de la réalité des postes et des projets
de l'établissement et d'assurer enfin
une gestion de proximité
nous sommes loin du compte aujourd'hui
la priorité financière donnée est un
autre système éducatif ne nous permet
pas d'oreiller la baisse du niveau des
élèves
les solutions ne sont pas seulement
d'ordre budgétaire les moyens sont
suffisants mais leur utilisation n'est
pas optimisé je finirai mon intervention
sur la place accordée par le prochaine
va aux collectivités territoriales
acteurs majeurs de l'éducation
les élus ne sont pas seulement des
payeurs ils doivent être également des
co décideur une meilleure implication
des municipalités assurera une meilleure
intégration des élèves dans la vie de la
cité
n'est ce pas également le rôle de
l'école j'illustrerai mon propos par un
seul exemple la réforme des rythmes
scolaires vous ne pouviez pas y échapper
monsieur le ministre
celle ci est absente de ce texte je le
regrette
elle s'est fait sans réelle concertation
n'a même pas été débattue devant le
parlement et a été imposée aux
collectivités
ah oui mais nous n'avons pas les mêmes
les mêmes sources de renseignements
monsieur baylet
nombre d'entre elles malgré une réelle
bonne volonté
or ont les plus grandes difficultés à
assumer cette évolution tant
financièrement que pratiquement
particulièrement zones rurales sont
faibles taux d'application à la
prochaine rentrée scolaire en témoigne
mal évalué elle sera créatrice d'
inégalité entre les territoires qui ont
été mis devant le fait accompli et en
conclusion nous avons ici au sein de la
haute assemblée en moins d'une semaine
balayés et dans tous les sens du terme
deux projets de loi qui ont pour
ambition de réformer tout notre système
éducatif de la maternelle au doctorat
cela représente un parcours qui commence
à l'âge de deux ans et qui se termina 26
voire 28 en un quart de siècle d'une
virée formé en une semaine
tout ceci en si peu de temps et de
concertation la cause n'aurait-elle pas
mérité plus d'échangés de dialogue
encore une fois avec mes collègues du
groupe udc
nous ne pouvons que regretter ces
constats je remercie
merci madame ferrat la parole le
président jean michel baylet pour le
groupe rdse
monsieur le président monsieur ministre
madame leur apporter à mes chers
collègues
si l'examen par le sénat en seconde
lecture du projet de loi d'orientation
et de programmation pour la refondation
de l'école devait s'apparenter à une
année scolaire
nous pouvons dire que nous entamons
aujourd'hui le dernier trimestre sur le
ministre tout près les essais rue de
grenelle ont clamé leur ambition pour
l'école ses ambitions très souvent
grandioses ont souvent cohabiter dans un
passé récent avec des moyens
malheureusement toujours plus limité
c'est ainsi que près de 10 ans dix ans
après le vote de la dernière grande loi
sur l'école l'échec scolaire n'a pas été
résorbés n'a même pas été réduit
d'ailleurs les inégalités sociales et
territoriales se sont elles dans le même
temps creusé en première lecture nous
ont été nombreux à dresser l'état des
lieux d'une école qui n'était plus en
mesure de mener à bien ses missions y
compris et je leur en donne acte sur les
bancs de l'opposition
notre collègue jean claude carle pointé
que je cite
chaque année notre écran les plus
inéquitables et plus inefficace roulante
mélo dressé cadets le constat que je la
cite l'école du 21ème siècle est en
crise à d'autres pays
alors bien sûr me connaissez je ne
nourrirait pas la polémique sur la
paternité des renoncements qui nous ont
conduits à cydia ses actuels mais je
souligne que le volontarisme affiché et
les moyens mobilisés par le gouvernement
quand vous même monsieur le ministre
faisant de l'éducation une priorité du
quinquennat constitue une rupture
salutaire avec le temps anciens car il y
avait urgence dans l'éducation nationale
était au bord de l'implosion avait des
effectifs rogner des enseignantes
déconsidéré et même résigné créer une
formation tronquée
alors que nous abordons mes chers
collègues la seconde lecture ce projet
d'aucuns voudront de s'interroger
cet été ce texte est-il irréprochable je
sais de mon expérience parlementaire
longue que la perfection ne se trouve
jamais dans un texte de loi et celui ci
monsieur mini ne déroge pas à la règle
bien sûr fruit d'une longue concertation
avec les différents acteurs du monde de
l'éducation puis soumis au parlement qui
au gré des lectures c'est suivre
l'assemblée le sénat l'a amélioré bien
sûr il est un texte de compromis
un texte pragmatique les reliques aurait
naturellement souhaité que soit retenu
un de leurs amendements sur les goûts
regroupement pédagogique en direction
des communes faisant partie ni d'un
regroupement pédagogique intercommunal
ni dans les pc exerçant la compétence
scolaire
nous soutenons néanmoins les nombreuses
avancées permises par ce texte tout
comme nous demeurons attentive au
pilotage et à la mise en oeuvre des
objectifs fixés
on ne le dira jamais assez une des
principales dispositions ce projet de
loi sinon la principale avec l'annoncé
bien naturellement de la création de
60000 postes
ça mérite quand même d'être rappelée
souligné mêmes mises en avant
concerne la formation des enseignants
elle qui fut lentement mais sûrement des
construites ces dernières années avec
une mastérisation rater et on a été
elle-même arriver à la situation les
personnes qui étaient chargés de
transmettre renseignement ne recevez pas
elle-même pour les préparer une belle
mission et à leur noble mission
l'enseignement minimum pour ce faire
être enseignant mes chers collègues
c'est être pédagogue et être pédagogue
cela s'apprend en cela la création des
écoles supérieures du professorat et
d'une éducation constitue une avancée
indéniable
ces dernières devraient être
opérationnels à la rentrée septembre sur
ministre et vous profiterez sans doute
de cet examen
pour nous exposer tout à l'heure les
ramène ce projet bien sûr les modalités
de ce déploiement que nous attendons
avec impatience
mes chers collègues la polémique
entourant la question de la refonte de
rhinau scolaire nous emballer l'instant
au moins deux permis de mettre en
lumière le rôle clé joué par les
collectivités territoriales dans notre
système éducatif
qu'ils s'agissent des communes pour
l'école primaire ou des départements les
régions pour le secondaire nos
collectivités
nos collectivités s'investissent et
investissent dans l'éducation pour peu
que leurs élus et leur pantin veille se
donner la peine de faire et de bien
faire la réussite de cette réforme
dépendra donc du partenariat entre
l'éducation nationale le mouvement
sportif et associatif et les
collectivités dans la coproduction
nouveau scolaires et périscolaires sur
l'ensemble du territoire et dans cette
optique
monsieur le ministre nous ont pris
connaissance du projet de décret
encadrant le fonds d'amorçage pour la
réforme des rythmes scolaires dans le
premier degré en application active 47
vous le savez cette réforme suscite
quelques inquiétudes quelques soucis
chez les mères notamment des petites
communes pouvez vous informer notre
assemblée des modalités d'attribution du
fonds
le montant de l'enveloppé consacrée et
la manière dont ce fonds sera abondé
lors de mon intervention en prélude à
l'examen du texte en première lecture
mes chers collègues je mobilisait les
collants vaut la peine certaines figures
du panthéon radical alain jean zay ou
ferdinand buisson
mes références seront aujourd'hui plus
modestes et je me bornerai à me
féliciter que les amendements déposés
par notre groupe est adopté par le sénat
bréhat lecture et était repris par
l'assemblée nationale
parmi ces 16 amendements
plusieurs tendances yeux une importance
particulière
c'est le cas de l'inscription de la
lutte contre les inégalités
territoriales au sein des missions du
service public de l'éducation
cela est également du renforcement de la
pause et parlementaires au sein
du conseil supérieur des programmes il
permettra au parlement bien sûr d'être
mieux représentée dans cette instance je
citerai également parmi ces
améliorations notoires l'inscription
dans le code de l'éducation de la lutte
contre l'innumérisme le développement
d'une politique de promotion de la
culture scientifique et technologique
mais aussi la nécessité de réformer les
deux hommes sans difficulté et le
renforcement indispensable des rased la
mise en oeuvre cet amendement permettra
de rendre l'école plus inclusive en
seconde lecture l'assemblée n'a que peu
modifié le texte voté le 24 mai par le
sénat sur les 26 amendements
beaucoup sont des rajustements
rédactionnelle jeu solide toutefois
l'option de celui symbolique qui propose
d'ajouter le drapeau européen au drapeau
français au frontispice l'établissement
lors de l'examen en seconde lecture la
commission des affaires culturelles
s'est félicité de l'équilibré entre les
deux chambres du parlement estime et qui
ne nécessite pas de retouche et je tiens
à ce stade a remercié mme hamm le
rapporteur face aux cards seront pour
son implication qui permettra aux
parlementaires rigoureux sans modifier
les quais libéral du texte notre groupe
défendant toutefois quelques
améliorations à pornic c'est notamment
pour appeler rembourser la liberté
pédagogique des professeurs et pour
assurer la présence enseignante dans les
départements ruraux
mes chers collègues monsieur ministre
lance hommes de sénateurs radicaux de
gauche et la quasi totalité des membres
de rds apporteront bien naturellement et
en toute logique leur voix à la
refondation de l'école pour des raisons
que je viens d'évoquer
mais aussi parce que ce texte prévoit ce
nouvel enseignement civique et morale
qui sera laïque c'est à dire
émancipateur parce qu'il accorde une
place essentielle à l'orientation afin
qu'elle soit choisie
et non plus subi par ce qu'ils prévoient
la création du service public du
numérique éducatif parce qu en fait ce
texte répond à l'ambition de refonder
l'école du 21ème siècle lieu de
transmission des savoirs et creuser des
valeurs républicaines
enfin pour terminer parce qu'il
contribue et il était temps à redonner à
la jeunesse de france qui en a bien
besoin
l'espoir en l'avenir merci monsieur le
président la parole est à madame corinne
bouchoux pour le groupe écologie
monsieur le ministre
madame la présidente de commission
madame la rapporteure mes chers
collègues
l'école doit être la sphère de tous et
non de quelques spécialistes qui aurait
limité pour parler alors que les autres
et coûterait nous voudrions en premier
salué comme l'a fait tout à l'heure
notre collègue brigitte contient mois
brigitte gonthier-maurin souligner le
bon esprit qui a présidé à ces travaux
où toutes les sensibilités ont pu être
entendus et où toutes les paroles ont
été prises en compte
bien sûr à des degrés divers aujourd'hui
nous sommes donc saisi en deuxième
lecture de ce projet de loi dit de
refondation de l'école de la république
et nous sommes satisfaits que la
rédaction en première lecture par le
sénat a été conservé nous avons partagé
ensemble est très largement le constat
suivant sur plusieurs points notre école
ne va pas bien elle va même parfois
assez mal les phénomène du décrochage
scolaire ou des élèves décrocher et
surtout le troublant problème de l'ennui
à l'école s'aggrave et nous avons essayé
collectivement d'oeuvrer pour progresser
vers une autre école une école qui
serait une école de lait coûte une école
de la bienveillance une école qui est du
créa la coopération plutôt que d'éduquer
en permanence à la compétition nous
l'avons déjà dit ici
nous souhaiterions une école qui
oeuvrent à une résolution non violente
des conflits avec des adultes formés à
ces techniques de gestion non violente
des conflits
nous appelons de nos voeux et ça a été
évoqué ici aussi une école qui éduque
sur la rareté et la finitude des
ressources
avec l'éducation à l'environnement une
école qui s'adresse à tous quel que soit
le milieu social quelle que soit
l'origine et qui prenne en compte toutes
les diversités une école où tous et tout
serait reconnu nous avons aussi pu faire
entendre le sens des parcours
artistiques qui donne tout son sens à
une véritable éducation artistique
beaucoup de nos amendements fruit de
débats engagés
et parfois animés ont été confirmés
pleinement à l'assemblée nationale ceci
prouve à notre avis que le travail et le
dialogue parlementaire entre nos deux
chambres est non seulement nécessaire et
utile mais extrêmement précieux nous
avons avancé sur un grand nombre de
points mais il faut reconnaître comme
nous l'avons dit qu'il ne s'agit que
d'un commencement de début de
refondation de l'école en dépit des
limites du texte que nous avons ici même
déjà signalé nous savons tous qu'il est
extrêmement difficile de réformer
l'école et donc il s'agit d'un
commencement d'une impérieuse nécessité
le chantier est immense les acteurs sont
nombreux les intérêts convergent
lorsqu'il s'agit de parler de la
réussite des élèves et diverge parfois
lorsqu'il s'agit du rythme de vie de
chacun un cap est maintenant fixée et
même si ce n'est pas comme je les ai
déjà dit ici à 100% l'école rêver des
écologistes il faut reconnaître quand
même que les choses vont
incontestablement dans le bon sens selon
nous l'une des questions centrales est
cruciale reste la formation des
enseignants qui fut sacrifié comme on
l'a vu ces dernières années les écoles
supérieures du professeur et de
l'éducation doivent être des lieux
structuré et vivant qui doivent donner
un nouveau souffle à la formation de nos
enseignants enseigner est un métier qui
s'apprend et pas seulement une vocation
nous savons que le calendrier sera
extrêmement difficile à respecter ça a
été évoqué en réponse à une question de
la présidente blandin lors des questions
d'actualité mais monsieur le ministre
nous attirons vraiment votre attention
sur le fait qu'il convient de prendre en
compte tout ce qui est actuellement dans
la loi pour que cela soit intégrée dans
les maquettes des sp dès la prochaine
rentrée
autre point qui nous tient
particulièrement à coeur la formation
continue des enseignants et nous savions
que nous avions posé la question ici
même au sénat y sommes très contents que
les députés est à l'unanimité adopté une
nouvelle rédaction via un amendement
indiquant je cite que chaque enseignant
est encouragé à se former régulièrement
et d'autre part qu'une offre de
formation continue adaptée aux besoins
des personnels d'enseignement est
proposé
notamment par le biais des écoles
supérieures du professeur à et de
l'éducation
c'est un sujet qui n'est pas tient
particulièrement à coeur même si nous ne
méconnaissons pas les problèmes de
remplacement et d'organisation que cela
peut poser c'est un sujet majeur dans
tous les départements et sur tous les
territoires ddt
ensuite il nous paraît nécessaire
d'assurer une formation continue de
qualité pour les enseignants tout au
long de leur carrière et estimant
extrêmement fructueux les changes de la
pratique entre enseignants expérimentés
en serre et enseignants débutants est
formateur aguerris enfin nous pensons
qu'il est extrêmement important que les
enseignants en exercice puisse
bénéficier des formations liées aux
gestion non violente de conflit et
notamment au travail de groupe et à
l'interdisciplinarité 3 nécessité qui
nous tiennent très à coeur enfin parmi
les nouveaux apports l'assemblée
nationale adopté un amendement
écologistes inscrivant la formation et
la scolarisation des élèves handicapés
dans l'émission des sp nous nous en
réjouissons
il s'agit là d'un signal fort envoyé à
ses élèves en situation de handicap aux
familles et aux enseignants qui vont les
accompagner
nous ne pouvons à ce titre que saluer
les 8000 postes annoncées à la rentrée
pour accompagner ces enfants en
situation de handicap qui permettra
selon nous d'aller vers une école plus
inclusive
notre modèle reste malheureusement très
éloignée des pratiques nordiques et vous
le savez comme moi nombre de parents ont
du mal à trouver une place en école
publique pour leurs enfants en situation
de handicap et un grand nombre d'enfants
restent encore déscolarisés c'est pour
nous une des questions qu'il faudra
régler prochainement
nous voulons préserver cet équilibre des
acquis de ce texte en deuxième lecture
au sénat et nous espérons que cette loi
donnera un nouveau souffle pour une
école de la réussite de la coopération
de la bienveillance enfin concernant la
lecture que vous avez fait chers
collègues du rapport de la cour des
comptes nous n'avons pas tout à fait la
même vision des conclusions que vous lui
prêtez et nous insistons sur un point
particulièrement important
la question des jeunes enseignants
envoyés dans les postes les plus
difficiles alors qu'on envoie les
collègues et les professeurs les plus
expérimentés déjà solide dans les zones
a priori moins difficile
il y a la une il y a là une question
très importante qu'il faudra réfléchir
comment concilier à l'avenir les statuts
des personnels et d'autre part les
évolutions qui permettrait d'être source
de justice pour tous les élèves
malgré les imperfections que nous avons
signalés malgré ses lacunes même si ce
n'est pas à 100% une loi écolo nous
voterons favorablement ce texte qui va
dans le bon sens je vous remercie de
votre attention
merci madame bush où la parole est à
monsieur jacques bernard magner pour le
groupe socialiste
chez le président monsieur ministre
madame et rapporteur madame le président
de la commission mes chers collègues
la première lecture du projet de loi
d'orientation de programmation de
l'école a donné lieu à près de 32 heures
de débat en séance au sénat
deux motions ont été déposés par l'ump
question préalable et renvoi en
commission heureusement elles n'ont pas
été adoptés sinon nous ne serions pas
aujourd'hui en train d'en débattre avec
plus de mille amendements déposés en
commission ou en séance tous groupes
confondus c'est à des discussions très
approfondies qui se sont livrés les
sénateurs durant quatre jours et quatre
nuits comme cela a été rappelé plus de
260 amendements ont été adoptés
parmi lesquels un grand nombre porté par
l'opposition pourtant les débats ont mis
en évidence deux conceptions très
divergentes voire opposées de l'école en
particulier sur le rôle de l'école
maternelle et sur la préscolarisation
sur le collège unique sur l'âge d'entrée
en apprentissage et sur l'étendue de la
scolarité obligatoire ou bien encore
tout simplement sur la pédagogie
grâce au travail d'enrichissement du
texte de dialogue approfondi initiée par
la rapporteure françoise cartron la
majorité de gauche à s'unir pour porter
une réforme phare du quinquennat de
françois hollande
concrétisant ainsi la priorité accordée
à la jeunesse par son gouvernement
comme françoise cartron l'a souligné
aujourd'hui encore le sénat a joué
pleinement son rôle de la cites en
apportant sa pierre
plutôt ses multiples petites pierres en
vue d'améliorer le projet de loi qui
était portée par le gouvernement les
principes fondamentaux de l'éducation
ont été réaffirmés par la création d'un
article l'article 3 qui fixe deux grands
objectifs tels que la lutte contre les
inégalités sociales et territoriales de
réussite la mixité sociale l'égalité des
êtres humains
cet article met également l'accent sur
la participation des parents en vertu du
possible du principe de coéducation la
notion d du kabyle itea et de tous a été
ajouté par ailleurs et a été mentionné
que le système éducatif favorise la
coopération entre les élèves
la commission a rétabli le principe de
l'accord des parents pour la mise en
oeuvre de dispositifs des dons en faveur
des élèves en difficulté pour lutter
contre l' orientation subie
la rapporteur a inscrit dans la loi la
possibilité d'expérimenter que la
décision d'orientation en fin de 3e
reviennent aux parents ou à l'élève
majeur a également été prévu un bilan
annuel dans les collèges et des lycées
des actions données à destination des
parents d'élèves et afin que les parents
s'approprient les locaux scolaires un
espace leur sera dédiée au sein des
établissements
l'information des parents et l'aide au
suivi de la scolarité de leur enfant
fait désormais partie intégrante des
missions des enseignants
toujours à l'initiative de la
rapporteure un même secteur de
recrutement pourra être partagée par
plusieurs collèges publics situés à
l'intérieur d'un même périmètre de
transport urbain
tout ceci afin de favoriser la mixité
sociale avec des articles 5 et 30 les
enfants de moins de 3 ans seront
comptabilisés dans les prévisions
d'effectifs enseignants des écoles qu'il
est scolarisé effectivement c'est une
chose qui était réclamée depuis
longtemps avant toute affectation en
école maternelle y compris pour les
enseignants déjà en poste
les enseignants eux devront bénéficier
d'éléments spécifiques de formation afin
de mieux s'adapter aux besoins des plus
jeunes de favoriser la mobilité des
enseignants entre les niveaux
d'enseignement
il a ainsi été ajoutés en maternelle
l'objectif de développer l'envié le
plaisir d'apprendre pour devenir un
élève
la rapporteure pour avis des affaires
sociales claire-lise campion a été à
l'origine de plusieurs amendements pour
donner corps aux principes de l'école
inclusive portée par le projet de loi
un amendement a été voté afin de prendre
en compte des projets linguistique des
élèves sourds et de leurs familles et
favoriser leur parcours scolaire selon
le mode de communication choisi par les
familles
un des apports majeurs de notre groupe
le groupe socialiste a consisté en
enrichissement des dispositions du
projet de loi en matière de santé
scolaire
la notion de parcours de santé autour
des visites médicales et de dépistage
obligatoire a été introduite la
périodicité le contenu des bilans de
santé obligatoire seront désormais fixés
conjointement par les ministères de
l'éducation nationale et le ministère de
la santé pour plus de cohérence et
d'effectivité l'émission de la promotion
de la santé ont par ailleurs été
complété par la détection précoce des
problèmes de santé ou carence de soins
l'accueil l'écouté le suivi
individualisé des élèves et la
participation à la veille
épidémiologique
ensuite le sénat a aussi renforcé le
rôle l identité des écoles supérieures
du professeur à l'éducation notamment en
permettant aux acteurs de l'éducation
populaire et aux associations agrées par
l'éducation nationale de participer à la
formation des futurs enseignants et en
intégrant des représentants de
collectivités locales conseils des
écoles il a en outre renforcé la
formation continue des enseignants ainsi
que celle initiale et continue des
personnels d'inspection et de direction
la place du sport a été affirmée dans le
projet de loi en inscrivant dans le code
de l'éducation la contribution apportée
par le sport aux apprentissages la
complémentarité entre les pratiques
sportives scolaires périscolaires ex
castres est extra scolaires ainsi que
les partenariats avec le mouvement
sportif lui-même tout entier le code de
l'éducation mentionne désormais
explicite explicitement les associations
éducatives complémentaires de
l'enseignement public comme des membres
à part entière de la communauté
éducative les parlementaires membres du
conseil supérieur des programmes sont
passés de 4 à 6 et seront désignés par
les commissions compétentes en matière
d'éducation de l'assemblée nationale et
du sénat
par ailleurs il a été précisé que les
membres du conseil supérieur des
programmes ne peuvent pas être
simultanément membres du conseil
national d'évaluation du système
scolaire ce sont des amendements portés
par l'opposition que je cite là
sur proposition de la rapporteure encore
une fois le rapport annuel du conseil
national d'évaluation du système
éducatif sera transmis aux commissions
compétentes du parlement et pourra
donner lieu à un débat en séance
publique les huit personnalités
qualifiées seront nommées après avis des
commissions compétentes de l'assemblée
nationale et du sénat
un moment de l'opposition une fois
encore il pourrait être saisie par ces
mêmes commissions au lieu d'être saisis
par les présidents des deux chambres
outre l'apprentissage d'une langue
vivante étrangère dès le cp prévu dans
le texte les sénateurs socialistes ont
promu la notion de diversité
linguistique que ce soit par le biais
des langues parlées au sein des familles
ou des langues régionales
le recours à des pratiques pédagogiques
spécifiques pour les élèves issus des
milieux principalement clergeau fog a
été étendu à ceux amérindiens il a en
outre été précisé que l' agence pour
l'enseignement des français à l'étranger
assurer ses missions de service public
de l'éducation en tenant compte des
capacités d'accueil de ces
établissements des amendements vivante
visant à favoriser le développement des
filières technologiques et
professionnelles ainsi que des
partenariats avec les pays tiers
ou bien encore une association plus
étroite du ministère de l'éducation
nationale aux missions de l'enseignement
du français et étrangers ont également
été adopté ce projet de loi a donc été
approuvé en première lecture par tous
les groupes de la gauche sénatoriale qui
se sont rassemblés pour porter unis la
refondation de l'école de la république
la deuxième lecture à l'assemblée
nationale
pendant cette deuxième lecture
l'équilibré général du texte issu du
sénat a été maintenue même si quelques
petites modifications ont été apportées
mais elle ne change pas le fond du texte
et convient désormais de conclure et de
voté conforme ce projet de loi afin que
sa promulgation intervienne dans les
plus brefs délais pour pouvoir le mettre
en oeuvre très rapidement avec la
préparation de la rentrée 2013
un dernier mot pour vous féliciter
monsieur le ministre vous remercier
surtout d'avoir donné à notre école de
la république cette loi fondatrice est
porteuse d'un avenir pour la jeunesse de
notre pays
le groupe socialiste la votera bien sûr
avec conviction et avec un enthousiasme
qu'il dise la nation
merci monsieur manier la parole est à
mme adam koné tbilissi pour le groupe
ump
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
je voudrais revenir sur la question de
l'échec scolaire qui est un sujet
récurrent
nous n'avons jamais vu autant d'études
rapport émanant de l' ocde ou de
l'éducation nationale elle même pour
nous expliquer que nos enfants de graves
lacunes
on a le sentiment que chaque fois le
nouveau mini jeu l'éducation nationale
bien dressé le même diagnostic de la
situation scolaire dans notre pays en
présentant des solutions qui permettront
de régler toutes les difficultés
or année après année nous nous rendons
compte que notre système scolaire et en
particulier le primaire et de moins en
moins performant plus on parle d'égalité
des chances puis l'école s'enfonce dans
un système incapable d'apprendre à nos
enfants à lire écrire et compter
correctement aux pauvres de nos débats
nous avons pu se rappeler que la france
a l'un des plus importants taux d'échec
des pays de l ocde en matière
d'apprentissage de la lecture et de
l'écriture
en effet 4 et l'absurde uys arrive en
6ème avec de graves lacunes mais cela
fait d'un peu de 10 ans messieurs
milices que l' ocde nous alerte sur la
chute du niveau scolaire ses fils sont
confirmées par le rapport du programme
international de recherche en et urs
polaire et dans ce rapport que j'ai
consultés il est écrit les élèves
français sont toujours les plus nombreux
à s'abstenir de répondre lorsqu'ils
réponses doivent être rédigées ils sont
aussi les plus nombreux à ne pas
terminer les épreuves mais ces mini j'ai
du mal à croire que la dégradation du
niveau des élèves date seulement des dix
dernières années
comme j'ai pu le lire de manière précise
dans l' annexe de votre projet de loi le
mal dont souffre notre système éducatif
est beaucoup plus ancien beaucoup plus
profond l'idée de vouloir rendre
responsable de cette situation
uniquement la précédente majorité des
dires dernières années n'est pas
vraiment très équitable
la dernière enquête pisa en 2009 a été
réalisée sur des élèves nés en 1993 et
bien pendant toutes ces périodes de 88 2
mai 88 à mars 2002
qui étaient nos ministres l'éducation
nationale nous avons de l'onec jospin et
puis jacques lang et puis françois
bayrou
et puis claude allègre et puis de
nouveau jacques lang donc avant même
cette période le niveau général des
élèves en fin d'école primaire était
déjà en chute libre comme le constatait
d'ailleurs une note d' alerte émanant
des services statistiques du ministère
de l'éducation nationale
la dégradation du niveau général n'est
donc pas récente mais dans tous les cas
chaque gouvernement a je crois une part
de responsabilité dans ce diagnostic
vous avez raison mais ce mise vouloir
vous donner la priorité aux primaires la
solution en revanche réside pas
uniquement dans une question de moyens
humains je ne crois pas que la réponse à
peu de nos difficultés nos six mines ne
se limite qu'à une question du nombre de
professeurs c'est d'ailleurs ce
qu'affirme la cour des comptes est c'est
confirmé par l' ocde
ce sont les questions de formation de
statut et de rémunération des maîtres
qui sont déterminantes
votre réforme aurait pu améliorer la
qualité de l'encadrement de la formation
des professeurs plutôt qu accroître leur
nombre dans de nombreux pays ce sont les
étudiants les plus compétents qui sont
incités à devenir enseignant car leur
rôle d'enseignant est essentielle la
vocation ne peut s'accomplir sans une
reconnaissance forte mais y compris d'un
point de vue financier
je rappellerai simplement que sous la
précédente législature d'ailleurs une
partie des économies qui avaient été
réalisées par le non renouvellement d'un
fonctionnaire sur deux a été réaffecté à
l'augmentation du salaire des jeunes
professeurs depuis ce depuis la première
lecture de cette proposition de loi
la cour d'appel la cour des comptes qui
a publié son rapport dit les et rappelle
que les enseignants appartiennent aux
cadres de la fonction publique de l'état
c'est-à-dire aux catégories a et a+ et
dans ce contexte c'est vrai que vous
serez sûrement d'accord avec moi leur
rémunération apparaît faible à plusieurs
égards certes les enseignants du premier
degré vous l'avez dit pourront bientôt
recevoir une prime
en revanche on avait pour unique vous
avez parlé de 400 euros après vous aviez
dit qu'elle serait très faible mais je
crois que vous êtes revenu à 400 euros
en tout cas ce que vous pourrez nous
préciser
le montant de cette prime je regrette
enfin que ce projet de loi n'évoque pas
suffisamment la formation des maîtres
attend la création d esprit dont on
ignore complètement le contenu on peut
former le souhait qu'elles seront plus
efficaces que les iufm la navette
parlementaire a permis quelques avancées
c'est vrai qu'ils doivent être évoquées
l'apprentissage précoce des langues
vivantes étrangères la promotion des
langues régionales la création d'un
service numérique éducatif la promotion
de la santé comme droit d'éducation
c'est une bonne chose
au moment même où le parlement augmente
le contenu des programmes
malheureusement vous décidé la
suppression du socle commun de
compétences pourquoi la définition des
compétences minimum et elle reportait à
un décret enfin votre projet de loi fait
l'impasse sur de trop nombreux sujets
je regrette par exemple que des
questions comme celle de l'autonomie des
écoles ou démission de leur directeur ne
figure pas je terminerai en vous disant
que je regrette beaucoup mais ce
ministre
de nombreux sujets relèvent enfin du
domaine réglementaire la modification
des programmes la réforme du secondaire
l'évolution du métier d'enseignant
il en est ainsi des rythmes scolaires et
vous savez sur ce sujet il faut
reconnaître que cette réforme ne donne
pas vraiment satisfaction ni aux élus
locaux ni aux familles en réalité je
crois qu'à la rentrée prochaine elle ne
concernera à peu près que 20 pour cent
dix élèves les choix qu'il ya un risque
de voir se creuser un peu plus les
inégalités entre des communes qui ont
des moyens financiers et les autres
voilà monsieur le ministre est
sincèrement je regrette je ne dirais pas
que ce texte demandant bichon mais je
crains qu'il ne soit pas en mesure de
régler les vrais problèmes
merci ma chère collègue
la parole est à madame maryvonne blondin
pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
d'amm la rapporteure mais sa collègue
les efforts budgétaires engagées par ce
projet de loi sont très importants avec
pour objectif de bâtir une école qui
place l'élève et sa réussite au coeur de
ses préoccupations en faisant en sorte
que chacun puisse accéder au niveau de
qualification le plus élevé possible
porteur d'une ambition d'égalité et de
justice
ce projet de loi d'orientation et de
programmation est un premier acte fort
qui affirme l'éducation comme moteur de
l'égalité des chances comme fabrique des
citoyens car c'est bien en place et dans
la cour d'école que prend forme le vivre
ensemble la fraternité le chantier qu'a
engagé le gouvernement est un défi
majeur qu'il faudra poursuivre une
feuille de route à respecter car comme
le disait aragon
rien n'est jamais acquis à l'homme ce
projet de loi innovant marquera de son
empreinte plusieurs sujets
l'augmentation des moyens l'adaptation
des rythmes scolaires l'augmentation du
nombre de professeurs la refonte des
objectifs du socle commun la priorité
aux primaires le service public et la
scolarisation des élèves en situation de
handicap
pour ma part j'assisterai sur quelques
points
tout d'abord l'école se dote de
personnel plus nombreux et surtout mieux
formés sans technique le talent n'est
rien qu'une sale manie affirmé georges
brassens
en effet si on signe et parfois un don
une envie transmettre des savoirs donner
à l'élève le goût et le plaisir je le
répète d'apprendre apprendre à
développer chez lui l'ex prix critique
est un véritable métier qui lui aussi ça
prend l'école s'ouvre de sur de nouveaux
contenus artistiques citoyens mais aussi
sur les familles ce projet de loi ce
aussi systématiquement
les parents à la scolarité de leurs
enfants en encourageant les actions
autour de la parentalité dans les
établissements une vraie ouverture avec
de vrais lieux d'accueil et pourquoi pas
monsieur le ministre
comme le demande la df et que je
soutiens ouvrir ces lieux aux services
publics acteurs de la cohésion sociale
en complémentarité du service de
l'éducation nationale pour construire et
mener à bien des projets avec les
parents et les enfants avec le principe
plus de maîtres queux de clages nos
enfants seront plus encadrées davantage
encouragées il en va de leur réussite de
leur épanouissement participe également
de ce mouvement les emplois d'avenir
professeur qui permettent aux jeunes
issus de milieux modestes de devenir
enseignant
ce texte favorise également l'accueil
des enfants de moins de 3 ans dans les
meilleures conditions et dans notre
république l'école maternelle demeure le
premier maillon de l'intégration et de
la réussite de tous les enfants elle
permet la socialisation la tolérance
l'égalité le respect entre filles et
garçons
elle favorise les apprentissages qui
permettront une entrée sereine dans
l'école élémentaire dans mon département
du finistère la scolarisation des 2-3
ans est une question importante elle
répond à une un réel choix des familles
qui sont atrache attaché or le taux de
scolarisation de cette tranche d'âge n'a
cessé de baisser
je voudrais aussi rappeler que ce projet
de loi a permis également d'avancé sur
l'enseignement de langues régionales
auxquelles vous savez mon attachement et
celui d'une beaucoup de mes collègues me
quittent l'hémicycle du sénat merci à
vous d'avoir suivi cette science si vous
souhaitez et la revoir à est disponible
en vod sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
à suivre l'émission politique de la
rédaction de public sénat preuve par 3
qui reçoit ce soir le président du
mouvement
au craft françois bayrou bonne soirée à
tous